[Music]  good evening  [Music]  oh wait you're just a civilian now  mr james ford general ryan's requesting  your  inimitable counsel no  he's offered to reinstate you  [Music]  from the top four hours ago the crew the  vander made first contact  stay there  they believe we're hostile  in the event of first contact humanity  must strike first  to ensure the continued survival  of our species operation  cosmic sin is now a go  but there is a space gate  they can bring their army here  what's the status of the cuba if we want  to launch the cue bomb  we need to get into orbit suit's up  that's something huh we didn't know  whether to burn it or put in a museum  i'm sure they said the same thing about  me  if we leave that door open we're gonna  charge in  we can make  the hard part is living with it  [Music]  you